mon frère et moi en faisant partie d'une
génération profondément frustré frustré
parce que à cause de l'actuel système de
production et de consommation
le réchauffement climatique devient le
plus important
les maladies chroniques telles que le
diabète ou l'obésité augmente et
aujourd'hui un enfant sur six
travaillent dans des ateliers de misère
tout cela à cause de quoi des profits
nous sommes frustrés parce que en dépit
de l'armée gens qui essaient activement
de changer la façon comment nos
ressources sont gérés nous n'arrivons
toujours pas à faire face un élite
minoritaire qui a un pouvoir écrasant et
nous ne sentions petit et en puissant
pour avoir un impact réel
frustré oui mais on lâche rien
heureusement on a une bonne nouvelle
pour noël quand même ici au tél on va
savoir trouver une solution un mouvement
citoyen basé sur des outils
technologiques capables de transformer
l'information un pouvoir un mouvement
capable de nous rendre à tous les
acteurs du changement
on l'appelle corps elle va déclencher la
vraie révolution de consommateurs alors
nous avons tous les deux étudié les
sciences politiques ça veut dire l'étude
de pouvoir et de sa distribution et en
essayant de démocratiser on pouvoir que
devient de plus en plus concentrée dans
les mains de quelques-uns
nous nous sommes impliqués dans des
causes auxquelles nous avons cru nous
avons participé pour des campagnes
politiques pour des campagnes des droits
de l'homme
nous avons signé plusieurs pétitions et
on a participé à plusieurs matchs marche
plus qu on peut en compter en plus quel
a été le résultat de nos efforts on
faible voire marginal et pourquoi parce
que précisément on utilise toujours le
même moyen pour nous battre contre la
concentration de pouvoir voir les
manifestations
les pétitions lettres représentant un
politicologue des institutions peut-on
faire plus existe il des voies
alternatives
oui mais pour ça il faut utiliser un
autre type de pouvoir beaucoup plus
puissant pensez-y en tant que citoyens
le pouvoir le plus significative que
nous avons et le vote mais il est rare
et pas très efficace très souvent à
cause des lobbys par exemple récemment
face à une demande des citoyens
européens pour mettre en place un
système d'étiquetage
comme vous voyez là les lobbys de
l'industrie alimentaire ils ont tout de
suite rassemblé 1 milliard d'euros pour
la bloquer au parlement européen est
bien bien sûr qu'ils ont réussi comme
consommateur par contre nous votons
chaque jour plusieurs fois par jour un
décidant d'acheter un produit un lieu
d'acheter un autre comme consom'acteurs
on est beaucoup plus puissant pour faire
face les effets négatifs de notre
système de pose de production voir le
problème de santé
déforestation la violation des droits
des hommes même violations de droits des
animaux
alors ce qu'on a vu c'est que pour
déclencher ce changement on a besoin de
deux choses d'abord il faut informer les
gens le faire devenir des consom'acteurs
qui savent vraiment ce qu'ils sont en
train d'acheter et deuxièmement il faut
regrouper nos voix nos voix de
consom'acteurs pour pouvoir pousser le
producteur à s'adapter à nos besoins nos
envies et nos valeurs réelles d'abord
points bien informer le consommateur a
tellement comment cela se passe alors
voyons ces doudous de rang pour voir
quels sont les meilleurs pour notre
santé on va regarder l'information
qu'ils nous donnent
mais voilà mais ça et personne c'est bon
même pour la rigolade prenons un
ingrédient on va essayer de le réciter
tous ensemble vraiment d'après moi ça
pourrait être un dérivé de mousse de
porc il est mort mais sous nos routes
notre peau chaque jour seulement parce
que le mec à la publicité les sexy non
mais sérieusement nous venons d'une
famille avec des gros antécédents de
cancer du sang et pour moi c'est
vraiment important de savoir c'est
mondia d'oran il contient ou pas des
ingrédients cancérigènes et je sais pas
le dire avec ce type d'information est
ce que c'est pire c'est que je peux pas
arrêter de soutenir les entreprises qui
assistent à mettre ce genre
d'ingrédients dans leurs produits moi je
suis choqué par le nombre d'abeilles que
morts chaque année en europe
c'est 30 à 35% de dix minutes
c'est encore pire aux états unis en
chine mais malgré mon indignation
je sais que contribuer à leur mise à
mort chaque jour avec mes choix d'achat
il avait une manière simple facile
rapide de savoir quels produits
contribuent à la mise à mort des
abeilles genèse les achèteraient plus
jamais plus jamais obs plus jamais et
bien et vous aussi vous avez sûrement
votre liste de besoins de préoccupation
quand vous allez acheter quelque chose
genre vous voulez éviter les ogm ou
ville de palm ou vous être allergique à
le lactose ou au gluten et b les
étiquettes telles qu'elles sont elles
sont pas tout à fait claires ni
intelligible et sans que les choses
soient claires on peut pas acheter
en accord avec nos valeurs et priorités
alors à former les consommateurs c'est
essentiel mais c'est pas suffisant
nous devons nous regrouper être capable
de parler directement aux producteurs
par exemple en apprenant qu'une
association de l'autre contre le cancer
dont un avis négatif à 1 will pour bébé
c'est normal que la main et c'est de
changer de marque même si celle ci coûte
10 on prend 20 35 plus cher si plusieurs
parents informés prendre la même
décision si normal que la marque essaye
de comprendre pourquoi il vient de
perdre tellement de clients et là encore
pour aider la marque à connaître les
vrais intérêts et valeurs de ses clients
et plus le coût de basse adaptés à leurs
besoins
et ça c'est le meilleure recette pour un
changement efficace alors petite
question pour l'audience qui parmi vos
un smartphone si je peux avoir enlevé de
main hop voilà alors presque trois
quarts des européens en longtemps et ce
genre d'outil cukor utilisé pour
facilement et rapidement informer les
consommateurs pour qu'ils puissent
devenir des consom'acteurs et deux qu'il
puisse se coordonner et on leur donne
ainsi le pouvoir et les moyens de se
faire entendre par les consomme par les
producteurs
et c'est ainsi que corps va arriver à
mettre au centre du marché pas les
profits mais les intérêts et les valeurs
d
consom'acteurs c'est pour ça que le 1er
août il que corps est en train de
développer une application mobile
capable de donner à chacun de manière
simple et rapide
l'information qu'il ou elle souhaite est
aussi de donner notre avis aux
producteurs
nous vous invitons à tous à les
connaître découvrir participé qu'aux
crier et rendre possible cet outil
indispensable à la consommation du 21ème
siècle alors les cartes sont déjà dans
le roman est maintenant il faut juste
bien les jouer maintenant c'est possible
rejoignez-nous et des marrons ensemble
la révolution des consom'acteurs merci